have you paid any attention to the
johnny depp and ever heard trials
i have uh watched quite a bit of it
because my wife really loves it and she
watches it in bed at night um so it's
raw like to me it's really because you
you've mentioned how complicated love
can be
and it's i've never seen i don't care
about the celebrity nature of it i don't
care if it was
i don't care who it is yeah but it's
just laid out in such raw form
the uh for the world to see it for the
world to see the toxicity but also the
passion and
and the
clearly sort of uh the drugs and the
drinking but also like
the longing and the dreams and i will
always be with you i will die for you
the the the place is the the roller
coaster of love and it's all
there
at the end past the end
so it's like uh i've also recently
reread the rise and fall of the third
reich about uh hitler nazi germany it's
the rise and the fall and it's
interesting to look at the entirety of
that process after it's all over many
many decades after it's all over that
book in particular written by the person
that was actually there and so here
we're seeing two people
in the context of the courtroom
analyzing this rise and fall of a love
affair
it's fascinating you know the truth is i
was telling my wife this actually just
the other day because she was asking me
what i thought about it
it makes me really sad
it's it's humorous don't get me wrong
there's a lot of parts in it that are
just really funny like
but yeah i look at it and i also see the
internet
and you know someone's always the
villain and someone's the hero
which is such a funny thing and we we
talked about a little about this offline
before we got on this but i have a real
firm belief in life that
it's just more complex than you think
always always and we in
johnny for instance
is very charismatic and and you you love
him and he's funny and this the way he
does things and he looks certain ways
and he says things
he's just you really love him and i feel
like and maybe i'm wrong on this but it
looks like the internet has really been
like
johnny is the winner amber is is the
villain and i kind of look at it yeah
and i kind of look at it and i feel like
were any of you in their bedroom like
were any of you
there for these things and i'm not
saying one way or the other like
the
all i see when i look at that is
two people with a lot of deep seated
hurt anger
and that anger is so poisonous to both
of them and they're and they're getting
through it in the way that they only
know how and
i'm not saying we should you know we
shouldn't be able to look at parts of it
and laugh about it and stuff and and be
virtuous or something but
just that there's not a hero
complicated yeah i think uh unless
you're you've been living with amber and
johnny you don't know just because one
seems more charismatic in the moment or
funnier or more believable even doesn't
mean that their truth
is the truth
and i i feel like they're still loved
there too which makes oh that's the
hardest part he won't even look at her
he looks down the whole time
and maybe people say well it's because
angers or
or hurt or whatever
but i s the way she looks and stuff it
feels
it just feels like there's so much hurt
there
that it hurt it hurts me to watch it i
just feel like oh my heart just like
aches for them and and for both of them
and i don't know either of them
personally
and you know i don't know
it just hurts but it's i've never i've
never seen sort of love laid out in this
raw kind of way it makes me
feel better about
like it almost gives you
seeing people have gone through a
struggle in this sort of mundane kind of
way
gives you room to struggle yourself
about the messiness of life so true like
you're supposed to
like relationship is supposed to be
simple and whatever but this like oh man
this it's like a heart
yeah
and and for the record like
i don't feel like it shouldn't be shown
like i think it's actually really
beautiful art and i agree there's gonna
be a lot of people who walk away from it
and are changed in certain ways or look
at things different i'm not saying it's
changing the whole world of johnny depp
trial but it's art it's just like you
would look at a painting and it might
affect you
um
my only commentary is more that
there's not i think it's silly when
people say who's right and who's wrong
and who's the clear villain and who's
the like we love as human we have to
have an answer for every we have to put
everything in a box and it's like well
we're looking at this and we're deciding
you're right and you're wrong and and i
just think it's it's silly unless it's
your life
you